بالفعل المعارك منتشره وممتده في المحورين
الجنوبي والشرقي من اوكرانيا والقصف
الروسي شامله عده مقاطعات قالت المصادر
العسكريه الروسيه انها قصفت دينيبرو
بتروفس وايضا كما انها قصفت اديسا وخاركب
تقول بانها تقصف الامدادات العسكريه
الغربيه التي تصل حيث مستودعات الذخيره
والقواعد العسكريه الاوكرانيه وهناك قصف
متبادل ما بين القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات
الروسيه ما اسفر عن قصف الجيش الاوكراني
لمدينه حيث المحطه النوويه في زبروجي كما
ان القصف يشمل مدينه خرسون او مقاطعه
خرسون حيث المناطق التي تسيطر عليها روسيا
هذا القصف كما اسلفت اسفر عن انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي نتيجه استهداف محطات
الطاقه
وانتاج الكهرباء هذه ليست للمره الاولى
التي تتعرض فيها المحطه النوويه ومحيطها
الى القصف هناك ايقاف مؤقت
لمنشات النوويه
وامدادات كهربائيه يعني من غير المحطه
الخاصه بانتاج الطاقه ننتظر الساعات
القادمه حتى نعرف مدى خطوره هذا الامر حيث
المحطه النوويه لكن لابد من ان نسلط الضوء
على ما يحدث في مدينه باقمت والتطورات بعد
سيطره قوات فاجنر على هذه المدينه قال
القائم باعمال المقاطعه هنا في دانيه
بوشيلي بان عمليات التنظيف مستمره التنظيف
من الالغام ومن مخلفات الحرب وذلك من اجل
افساح الطريق للمؤسسات الحكوميه والمؤسسات
المدنيه لبدء عملها بانشاء يعني الشبكات
شبكات التواصل
واعاده بناء يعني البنى التحتيه المدينه
على غرار في مدينه ماريوبل سابقا كما ان
قائد قوات فاقنار
اكد بان مهمته هي السيطره على مدينه باقمت
وهو اتم هذه المهمه وسينسحب بالفعل في
الخامس والعشرين من هذا الشهر ولن يحارب
ولن يقاتل في اي محور اخر مسلطا الضوء على
المعارك في جنوب مدينه
التسليم والتسلم بين القوات او الجيش
الروسي يوم الخميس المقبل 30 بسلاسه ان
هناك بعض التعقيدات ربما
انا يعني من مصادرنا العسكريه احمد اؤكد
لك بان القوات الروسيه حاضر على الارض في
باخمت تقاتل في محوري ايفانا
المحور الجنوبي الذي يشهد حشودات عسكريه
اوكرانيه كبيره شنت هجمات من اجل العوده
واعاده السيطره على
القوات الروسيه المدفعيه الروسيه سلاح
الجو الروسي يعمل في ذلك المحور القوات
الروسيه حاضره وهي تقاتل قوات فاجنر اكملت
مهمتها ولا تقاتل الان في مدينه باخموت هي
تستعد للانسحاب من يعمل الارض على الارض
الان في مدينه باقمت هو الجيش الروسي وحده
لا غير لكن هناك ايضا تطورات في محاور
افديفكا ومارنكا حيث ان هناك امدادات
عسكريه كبيره حسب القائم باعمال الرئاسه
هنا دينيس بوشليم فيكا هناك امدادات
عسكريه بشريه وبالمعدات في مدينه
المتاخمه طبعا والقريبه جدا هو هذا كله
المحور الشمالي الغربي حيث مارينكا باخموت
هناك امدادات عسكريه كبيره وهناك احتمال
لشن هجمات اوكرانيه مضاده ضد الجيش الروسي
تقول المصادر المحليه بان الجيش الروسي
مستعد وعد يعني خطط دفاعيه وتحصينات لمنع
اي هجوم اوكراني يمكن ان يحصل في الايام
القادمه بشكل عام المعارك مستعره على جميع
المحاور ان كانت الجنوبيه او الشرقيه هناك
تقدم بطيء للقوات الروسيه في محور مارينكا
واتمام للسيطره على باقي وعمليات يعني
تنظيف كما يصفها هنا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات